well, madam president, that's it,
ladies and gentlemen,
I am very happy, madam
president, to welcome you to paris
with the members of the european commission
during this first week of the
french presidency of the council of
the european union
for several months now we have been
working  together in the preparation of
this presidency so that france
takes over from our predecessors on the
council and here we are now the
work so yesterday and today with
the commissioners the members of the
government we were able to launch
our work very concretely with our
parliamentarians too  is together
European Commission and
French President we have I believe the same
desire to make this semester a
useful moment for Europe of efficiency
in carrying out concrete projects
resolutely at the service of
Europeans Europeans and our future projects
and I wanted  thank you for
also taking the time this morning to come and
honor the  memory of two great
european figures they are jean monnet
and simone veil in the pantheon
so i'm not going to go over the
whole program here it wouldn't be
possible it would make a lot of sense but
our desire to punctuate the next few
months with first the  advancement of texts
that are planned and that we have
collectively pushed forward to have
a more carbon-free society and economy,
in particular with the
climate package and therefore during this semester we will have
the possibility of
advancing several subjects such as the
mechanism, in particular at the borders
as well as all the mechanisms
that will make it possible to accelerate the
decarbonization of our transport
the improvement of electrical systems
the decarbonization of our housing and
so on we will also have
the possibility during this summit of
advancing our
digital agenda with two major
directives  mad at and we are
very committed to being able to move forward on this
point is don  c regulate both the
market and the content and create a real
European model
we will also have a semester I believe
extremely important in terms of
social convergence and social justice
for a more inclusive
Europe fairer between women and men with
important texts  for
decent wages and for equality between women and men
in terms of pay and on company
boards of directors,
and we will also have a whole
agenda in terms of
border security or defence, for example,
very structuring the coming weeks
will be punctuated by several  events
a summit in brest in february on the
oceans to our strategy
a summit in brussels
african union european union we
have this common strategy that we
want i would say rebuilding this
new alliance with the
african continent is an immense amount of work done
by the matter committee  I sleep
whole from sanitary to economic
to mobility to mi  rations we
will then have on March 10 and 11 this
informal summit in France which will
allow us both to have a
strategic discussion on defense
a strategic discussion were our
macroeconomic model and our news
our new governance but at the heart
of this basically the  strategy for
building the European model of growth
and autonomy with many
projects that we have started to
finance but a strategy that we
want to share and implement and
this new model of growth
of investment of production
of autonomy is an element  key for me
for this semester but especially for the
coming decade we will then obviously have
the council in March then the summits which
are planned in particular on the
issue of the balkans is obviously the
geopolitical situation which will lead us
in the coming days and
weeks to  act together and very
clearly, in particular for
European security, the question
Ukrainian and several others I
do not want here in his introductory remarks to
be longer and I had the opportunity
in December to present all of
our lines of work but alongside the
commission with all the members
of the council  of the European Parliament and of the
European Parliament, we are at work to be
able to make this semester by semester
fully useful and advance this
common ambition that we have here,
Madam President, I wanted to say
by thanking you for your presence,
you and all of  your college as
well as teams in paris during
these two days thank you shearer that thank you
sir president cheikh emmanuel i am
delighted to be here with the college of
commissioners on the occasion of the launch
of the french presidency of the
council france is taking on this fine task  in
a very particular context,
the health situation linked to
coville 19 remains worrying but we
are taking strong action on the
vaccine front
this has enabled us to achieve a
vaccination rate of nearly 70% of the
entire population
and nearly 80% of adults
in europe not only have we
delivered 1.2 billion doses of vaccines
to europeans but  at the same time, we
have exported 1.5
billion doses of vaccines to more
than 150 countries
to the shared fleet, moreover, we are supporting the economy
in a massive way, in particular thanks to
the nexen rich new recovery programs
of 400, sorry, 800 billion euros
and that  we do not make us forget the
other problems, for example the bull
had said, Mr. President, our
neighborhood is the scene of
significant tensions as illustrated by the
military pressure of russia
on Ukraine and this intimidation vis-à-
vis moldova I  i am therefore delighted that a
country with the political weight
and experience of france is assuming the
presidency of the council at such a delicate moment
because the voice of france speaks loud and clear
and france takes europe to heart
we have major projects in the world
the first of course is that of the
climate the commission has made
ambitious detailed proposals to
achieve our objective of 55
% reduction in greenhouse gases by 2030
we want to do it in an
economically efficient and fair way  from a
social point of view and I know how
much this balance is important to you
Mr. Chairman and we
fully share this ambition we are
therefore counting on the French presidency
to advance its proposals
secondly the digital transition
our common ambition is to make
europe a true
digital power in the world shaped according to
our own rules and values
mulated ambitious proposals last
ear our laws on the m
rkets digital services in order
to foster innovation while putti
g the big platforms in the face  to
their democratic responsibility
I hope and I am sure that the
presidency  French before will be quickly on
these subjects because we know that they are
at the heart of the concerns of European citizens
more generally we must continue
to strengthen our economic model, as you said
,
that of in and as an economy that is
both competitive and  social we are
working on a new
european
growth model shape of course by the
digital pact resilience in
line with next generation eu is based
on excellence sustainability and
competitive european sectors here
again i am delighted to  see our
priorities converge, for example our
initiative to develop a
competitive hydrogen sector to achieve
the objectives of the green deal
for europe
finally for this new
growth model I would like to mention the
proposal made by the commission
three weeks ago on taxation
multinationals the european union is
among the first to implement
this historic reform on the t  to the
minimum taxation as agreed to the water these two
hours and the g20 I hope that we
will reach a rapid agreement during
the French presidency because this
reform is necessary for equitable
global growth another important subject
border management  and the strengthening of
the schengen space our space of free
movement
various crises have weakened this space
which is nevertheless at the heart of the
european project we therefore want to restore
preserve and strengthen the opening of the
internal borders of the
european union to do this we have
presented its
proposals for reforms in this direction in
December and I hope that the
French presidency will give the necessary impetus
to progress on this dossier, of
course, this also involves
strengthening the management of the
external borders
the fight against the networks  of smugglers
and work with countries of origin
and transit, this is why I
also want  to see rapid progress on our
migration and asylum park which
precisely offers this global approach
then we agree that we need
a real defense
union a defense union which prepares us for
future new threats, for example the
next hybrid attack from the cac wherever
they come from so let
's agree on our priorities thanks to our
strategic compass, that is to say a
kind of white paper on defense and
I am delighted that the French president
be committed to this file I expect a
lot from the discussion that will take place
on this subject in the framework of the
summit that we are going to have in March
I believe that it is high time
for European defense to move on to
higher gear
finally I would like to discuss our relations
with africa of course in the
context of the co pandemic quickly we
must increase our support for this
continent both in terms of
vaccines and the economic consequences
but  well beyond this
crisis africa is obviously a
key partner for the future of our continent
because it is an
economic and demographic geopolitical space which will be
essential in the world of tomorrow so I look
forward to discussing the means
of  deepen our partnership at the
summit we have in brussels the
european union and africa in february and
now they are sketching out an
ambitious program for the next six months
you can count, mr
president, on the commitment of the
commission and thank you very much  to
have us also if
madam madam president sir
we are going to take
questions four in all and the first
goes to abeda romano where he comes from and
24 ore'
day madam hello sir i would like to
ask a question to mr
president
i  would like to come back to
the quirinal treaty that you signed
with italy a few weeks ago with
great fanfare I notice that in the
comments of the government  french you
continue to highlight the relationship
with germany and i wonder if
this new relationship with italy is
intended to stay behind in
relation to the franco-german relationship
first of all if the objective is not
only to
continue on very specific very specific
objectives such as the reform
of the stability pact or nuclear power
and since I can ask a
question jean would ask a second
about the political uncertainty in
italy is what you are very busy
with  the possibility of a change of
government in italy thank you sir
thank you very much for your question I
am not used to commenting on
political situations in our neighbors
and in friendly countries I can simply
say that today we are
very lucky  to have a president of the
republic such a courageous european president of the council
and a friend of france
and i see this is a chance for
france and for us.  As for
the quirinal treaty as we
presented it a few weeks ago with the
chairman of the council to guy, it covers an
extremely wide set of songs, I
'm not going to repeat them here, but
it's a very intimate cooperation that
the  italy and france are building through
this treaty because the friendship
between
our two countries if that is the case all
bilateral relations within
the european union
further strengthen the european project it takes
nothing away from it it completes it  makes it
even safer
creates more intimacy between our societies
our cultures our intellectuals our
economies so this treaty for me is
first of all the first of its kind it is an
important step and it consecrates and
consolidates the strength of our friendship of
our ties
this approach is
neither a substitute nor a comparison, if
I may say so, with the friendship
between germany and france that's always
how i saw things we
have we know our relations  and
I will not go here into what
could raise earlier
two theses or literary or
psychoanalysts who are well known on
the triangle of desire but
when we look at 3 is always
something that is complicated me
I like to do  simple and so I think that
the mythical we have with
germany does not take anything away from the mythical we
have for italy and vice versa and
that the more elsewhere we can
operate at 3 for europe the more we
will do useful work
and  so we are going to multiply the
initiatives with italy we will
therefore also multiply the initiatives
each time that it will be possible with 3
and moreover you mention the
hollow platform that I was able to sign with mario
draghi we discussed it
also proposing with the Chancellor the fleet is
a real discussion in all of this is
done in intelligence and friendship
and therefore for me this relationship is
not built alongside and in symbiosis
with the friendship that we  s we have
with germany but i think we have a
lot of things to do in
franco-italian italo-french
and together in europe it's
about jérôme grivet from the
ftq - so you made
the affirmation of the power of
l  europe one of the priorities one of
your priorities for the next few months
so how do you expect to obtain
concrete results
precisely during the semester and to
begin with on the crisis in kazakhstan where
the government has received harper support from
the russians and authorized the  police to fire
their warning at the demonstrators
began to respond
yes
maybe a comment on the
situation in kazakhstan
i am following the situation in kazakhstan with
great concern
the rights and safety of citizens
are paramount and must be
guaranteed and i call  at the end of the
violence and with restraint the
european union is ready to help
where it can
without this canadian madam president
we are from l  a time
extremely vigilant we have called
for de-escalation and we are also
very mobilized to
be active in this profoundly new context, but I
have nothing to take away from what
Madam President has just said about the
power and the concrete agenda during  this
semester we will first
complete the strategic compass which
is our common geopolitical and
defense strategy in europe 1 we will have
a discussion at the informal summit in
march we will conclude it at the formal summit
in march in brussels which will
allow us to have a  common position
in europe and then in nato and to act
together in a much more
coordinated way second point we
also have an approach in terms
of industry of common projects that we
will continue to advance this
will also be the subject of the summit  informal of
March 2, that is to say build them what
they are the foundations of this
strategic autonomy the possibility
of having an industry
stronger European defense and to have a
stronger technological autonomy
and that is an absolutely key point for the
reality of this subject third point we are
going to continue to move forward in a
very concrete way on a culture
of common intervention it is  the
continuation of the
European intervention initiative that we have launched and
which will continue and be enriched in
the coming months with several
operations elsewhere which will be inspired
by this method, fourth point,
we will together
also propose
our vision  of a
European security architecture
so we are already doing it
by situation
on the case of Ukraine for example
it is the Normandy format m with the
Chancellor of Cholet will propose to me to
hold a new meeting in the
coming weeks including dismissing him
but  we can clearly see that the whole
geopolitical situation of the region
requires that europe can better be
able to propose its vision of
things to act and  sit around the
table with all the
stakeholders to move forward on this subject these
are some of the axes on the
matter that you mentioned in this case to
those of dpa
the president mr president
the european union is currently
excluded from the  discussions with russia on
a possible new
european security architecture
is too effectively was
it a mistake not to organize
a summit with mr
putin as mrs r qu proposed
a few months ago and what is
what can the european union do
to change this situation
is also our question for
mr president are you
still talking to mr
putin on a moratorium on the
medium range nuclear missile thank you
very much
I believe that one thing is clear,
no solution will necessarily go
through Europe,
whatever the solution, it must
go through Europe and the
European Union.  t very present as
regards, for example, support for
the uchronia i was art in october we
financially support luc remy
enormously with 6 billion euros we
are essential as regards
ukraine's energy security
l  the european union also imposed
the sanctions against russia for its
aggression all these are facts in this
theater and as you said
mr president we have the
format of normandy with france
and germany and of course the countries
Europeans form the majority in nato
and nato is crucial in this dialogue,
even for me it is important to
also reflect with you, Mr.
President, during this presidency on
the idea of a European security architecture and w
will come up with our
idea on that our architecture put it
on the table discuss it and
develop it together so once again
there will be no solution except
with europe with regard to its
on
the subjects q  Since you first mentioned
I think it's a good thing that
there are discussions between russia and
the united states of america
on the tensions that exist around
the Ukrainian situation and even more
broadly so I m  I welcome it and I
think that this discussion is
important I note moreover and
I also welcome that the
coordination between Europeans and
Americans is exemplary on this subject
since we had the opportunity with
President Byden to have several
exchanges  before and after his discussions
with President Putin
second point if these exchanges
concern the Ukrainian question
several other questions of
bilateral interest in no case obviously a
discussion of the European security architecture
which is first and foremost the
question of Europeans and  so it's up to
us to propose the
European security architecture we want
I mentioned them at the 2019 NATO summit
and it's up to us to build it  e in
Europe to share it with our allies
within NATO and
to share it with our neighborhood
because we are a geopolitical power
so I think that was obviously
how things happened and will
continue to  madam
president recalled the commitment of
the european union with regard
to ukraine I will not go back to that we
have with the president with
chancellor merkel at the time
indeed proposed to re-engage in a dialogue
structured with russia france
moreover re-engaged as you
know in the spring of 2010 9 with several
initiatives and we continue to
do so
that is
why france continues to exchange with
russia I myself had two conference
calls  very long with
President Putin in recent weeks
and I will have more in the coming
days
I think that the European Union must
dialogue with Russia dialogue
is not to concede dialogue  er is to be
able to first take stock of our
disagreements but try to build
the future we have sanctions that
exist because of
the Ukrainian crisis and the 2014 invasion
they are maintained but we
need  a dialogue with russia,
which by geography and history
is an essential actor for this
european security architecture that
we must build, so i continue to
advocate this frank dialogue
requiring coordinated
because the member states of the
european union  do not all have the same
history with regard to russia nor
either the same geography and therefore the
same concerns and that is
also why I spent a lot of time for
my part through the bilateral trips
that I  have done it is all of my
colleagues to understand this history
its concerns and to integrate them
the European security architecture
must integrate all its stories and
its requirements finally I remain
completely p  in the context of this work
and this approach obviously
integrating all military issues
and arms control in Europe,
whether it is a question of medium-
range missiles or nuclear capabilities
, all of this must  be taken into
account I remind you one by a
unilateral American decision we
are no longer covered by the said treaty
is over which is a concern
for many states in particular in
central and eastern Europe so we
do not  can't stay in this
situation it's our responsibility
we're going to do it all together
the last question is asked by m
what i tell you bfm tv
hello madam president hello
mr president you said
in an interview that the west indies
vague it was  irresponsible people and
that an irresponsible person was no longer a
citizen could you clarify
this idea which is not clear to
everyone, including within the
government and then you  you also
expressed the desire to complicate life,
to put it politely,
of these anti-vaccines with additional constraints
on a daily basis is
this a position that you share
with the president of the commission with
your European partners and do
you  intend to push it in this is a
serious question in the coming months
complicate the life of some
so that they get vaccinated to
accelerate the vaccination campaign
day thank you
on your first question first
I want to reassure you
the government
which  I was given to see Wednesday
understand very well what the President of
the Republic is saying and more seriously
on the first subject that you
mentioned I repeat it during the greetings there to
be a citizen is to have rights
and duties and these are  first of all
duties, and I had the opportunity to
say this on several occasions, also the
concept of freedom which is brandished
today by some of our
compatriots to lead  the freedom
not to have myself vaccinated it stops
where the freedom of the other is at
that moment hampered where the life of
the other can be put in danger it must be
clearly seen that these are not
statements that I made it was in
the two-hour interview with eight of
our compatriots that one of your
colleagues had selected
all of the people with whom I spoke
was
a didier with regard to our compatriots
who do not want  to be vaccinated
I had two caregivers in front of me who
told me but we think that we
should no longer treat people who are
not vaccinated when they arrive at the
emergency room from where I am I can
not not be concerned  by this I saw
doctors' forums saying we
no longer want to treat people who
arrive in the emergency room who are not
vaccinated and therefore we can be moved
by forms of expression that seem
familiar that I totally assume
myself I am  moved by the situation in
which we are  s the real fracture
of the country is there when some make
their freedom which becomes an
irresponsibility a slogan not only do
they endanger the lives of others
but they restrict the freedom of
others
it is a question of I cannot accept it and
I cannot allow debates to prosper in
our country which would consist of
saying do we not treat them by our choices,
no, but I also said very
clearly so
what I am saying is that being a
citizen also means accepting  the duties that
go with this citizenship and therefore
when you are a citizen you have to agree to
fulfill your duty
then yes I fully assume and that is
what we have been doing since last summer
we have a strategy which is simple
vaccinate vaccinate  vaccinated she is
European and frozen still reminded
several times fortunately that we
have Europe for from the beginning to have
obtained these doses and then to be the first
continent of production and production
open for the world e  whole because
we have exported more
doses are given than we have kept for
ourselves so vaccination is
our priority
then the second pillar is the
health pass becoming a vaccination pass
why because it is a  mechanism
which makes it possible to protect each
other when you are in a
common space and it is also a strategy which
has been adopted everywhere in europe with
different technical methods but
which is protected for others and to say to each other
when you go to the  restaurant when we go to the
show
when we are in the same room and well
we know my status
and we move forward and I must also say
that the vaccination pass is inspired by
the initiative that had been taken before
us by Luxembourg  germany
others we had a health pass
as you know which allowed
to be vaccinated or tested in places
of conviviality
several of our neighbors had put what
they call the 2g or two I have more
before  that we come to his
decisions we had to either be cured or
have his full vaccination schedule so
it's a completely European movement
and who does what who puts
restrictions on people who
are not vaccinated and so this movement
you see it everywhere  in europe then
some make the vaccination obligation
above a certain age but
most countries put constraints on
social life by saying if you are not
vaccinated you do not have access to this place
you do not have  no access to this activity
and we are obliged to do it to
encourage each other to push it does
and I say it with a
lot of will and strength we
must do this we must do it
for all of our compatriots who
are doing  the effort to be vaccinated and
which by the irresponsibility of certain
others sometimes the choices assumed
are contaminated and we must
also do it for our compatriots who
sometimes let themselves be taken in by speeches
obscurantist by speeches of fear
and do not protect themselves
while science, research and
European technological and productive excellence
allows them so there it
was, I believe, my responsibility for
2-2 summit a bit of a tear is  what
I did this week so
that things can move forward even more
quickly here is
a
very important discussion that we are now having the
discussion what does
freedom mean freedom always
combined with responsibility and not
only  responsibility for
myself but also their
responsibilities for those who are
close my neighbors my friends my family
the others and I believe that one and
the other will tomorrow be in hand and that
is the discussion we are having now
and in government must also protect,
that is to say the vaccination pass
is a form of protection for those
who are vaccinated so it is like
Mr. President
the dcri to an instrument that  e of course the
governing government all used
me i believe this discussion about
responsibility freedom is a very
important in our society during a
pandemic
thank you very much in his place in chelsea
thank you all give you back to the prime
minister and the government